in April 20 20 the long-running CBS
crime drama NCIS wrapped up its 17th
season after all these years the cast is
still headed by Mark Harmon as special
agent Gibbs and the 17th season saw
appearances from classic characters like
Ziva dahveed and Jimmy Palmer played by
Cody to Pablo and Brian decent
respectively obviously the NCIS team
that we first met in 2003 has changed
quite a bit over the years other than
Mark Harmon David McCallum is the only
series regular who's been around since
the very beginning he plays dr. Donald
ducky Mallard as you probably know but
few former NCIS characters are missed as
much as Michael Weatherly's Tony DiNozzo
people just loved tuning in to watch his
antics every week I think it's a better
rule rule 38 oh so it's no surprise that
many fans were downright disappointed
when he left the show at the end of
season 13 his departure left us with two
burning questions one
why did Weatherly decide to hang up his
badge after 13 seasons and two well Tony
DiNozzo ever make another appearance on
NCIS it's hard to say remember what
happened in the season 13 finale Tony
was mourning the alleged death of Ziva
with whom he'd always enjoyed a loving
but complicated relationship after
Ziva's supposed death
Tony learns that she'd given birth to
their child a secret she decided to keep
from Tony to avoid complicating their
lives talk about an emotional burden
though Tony is understandably shocked by
this news he takes to fatherhood quickly
by the end of the episode
Ziva's alleged killer has been taken
down by the team and Tony has made a
really tough decision he's going to step
away from NCIS to raise his daughter and
rebuild his life of course everyone is
devastated by his departure but they
certainly understand his reasoning it's
one of the most emotional send offs in
the history of the series but why did
Weatherly step away from NCIS
after such a long run ultimately he left
for the same reason that many people
leave their jobs after 13 years he felt
it was time to move on in an interview
with The Hollywood Reporter he said he
was burned out by the show's taxing
schedule as to how Tony's story wrapped
up Weatherly said it
really felt like a circle that had gone
all the way around and I really felt
happy with the resolution of character
and my time on the show Weatherly left
the show on good terms with the cast and
crew and he quickly landed a role on
another CBS series while he was
preparing his departure from NCIS it was
announced that he would be the lead of a
new primetime drama bull the show was
somehow inspired by the life and times
of the decidedly uninspiring dr. Phil
defines Weatherly playing a psychologist
dr. Jason bull the head of a jury
consulting firm as of the making of this
video
bolla still on the air after four
seasons but the question remains will we
ever get to see whether Lee played Tony
again well there have been plenty of
rumors that Tony would be returning to
the show which began pretty much the
moment he left this speculation went
into hyperdrive during the show's
sixteenth season that's when it was
revealed that Ziva was still very much
alive and when cote de pablo did indeed
return to the show fans were fairly
certain that Weatherly would soon follow
suit in fact even before de Pablo's
return
Weatherly hinted on Twitter that he was
totally down with returning to NCIS
writing in February 2018
yes I believe Ziva is alive and I will
always be ready to play DiNozzo when the
time is right many fans were convinced
Tony would be making an appearance on
the season 17 midseason finale
along with Ziva and their daughter Holly
but when the episode aired only Ziva
made an appearance although Tony and
Holly were mentioned in the episode
frankly we're still waiting to see
whether Tony DiNozzo will ever make his
grand return to the show don't let down
the team DiNozzo check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you